[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
[Jubel] Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute kommt wieder ein cooles Rezeptvideo von mir,
und zwar ein Rezeptvideo aus der Rubrik
[Doing] „Meine Frau hat mich gezwungen, Dinge zu machen,
für die ich eigentlich gar keine Zeit habe.“
Sally ist gerade drüben in der Küche und macht ihr Kochbuch,
inzwischen schon seit 3 Wochen.
Während sie das Kochbuch bearbeitet, braucht sie Ruhe.
Damit sie Ruhe hat, muss sie mich beschäftigen.
Deswegen entstehen gerade diese Videos.
Ich bin bei uns hier in der privaten Küche.
Die habt ihr vielleicht noch nicht so oft gesehen.
Bei uns gibt es eigentlich keine private Küche;
ob das jetzt hier oder drüben ist – wir kochen überall.
Aber cool, wenn man ausweichen kann.
So sieht es hier aus.
Nicht erschrecken, dass es etwas ganz Anderes ist.
Ich mache heute einen coolen Kuchen.
Meine Frau hat mir ein Rezept aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar war das ursprünglich ein Oreo Cheesecake.
Sie hat mir alles schön hingeschrieben,
dass es wirklich auch Kinder verstehen.
So sieht es aus. Das sind die Oreo Kekse.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich will sie überraschen.
Eigentlich denkt sie, ich mache den Oreo Cheesecake.
Aber ich mag Oreo nicht so sehr,
[Aufschrei] muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Kann ich ruhig öffentlich sagen.
Ich will keinen Shitstorm dadurch bekommen.
Ich habe mir gedacht: Hey, ich habe noch im Süßigkeitenschrank
- wir haben da einen kleinen Süßigkeitenschrank –
die Leibniz Cheese-and-Cream Kekse gefunden und habe gedacht,
hey, dann mache ich einfach
[Doing] Leibniz Cheese-and-Cream Cake à la Murat, genau.
Hat es noch nie gegeben.
Oreo Cheesecake ohne Backen gab’s schon öfter.
Deswegen mache ich einen Leibniz Keks-and-Cream Cheesecake, genau.
Eine ganz coole Geschichte.
Geht ganz einfach. Das bekommt wirklich jeder hin.
Das heißt, wenn ihr ein Mann seid, könnt ihr das auch hinbekommen.
Alles easy und fangen wir an.
Für den Boden einfach 1 Packung Leibniz Cheese-and-Cream,
das sind 228 g Kekse. Dann brauchen wir für den Boden 100 g Butter.
Für die Füllung brauchen wir 400 g Sahne, 4 TL San-apart,
200 g Frischkäse, 250 g Quark
und später braucht ihr nochmal 2 TL San-apart,
d.h., insgesamt 6 TL San-apart.
Dann haben wir 80 g Puderzucker, 1 TL Vanilleextrakt und später,
wenn ihr Lust habt, nochmal die kleinen Schoko-Minis zum Verzieren.
Bei diesem Rezept ist es ganz wichtig:
Es muss alles funktionieren, weil ich nur 1 Packung Kekse habe.
Deswegen fangen wir an mit dem Keksboden. Wirklich total easy.
Ihr könnt wirklich jede Kekssorte nehmen, die ihr wollt.
Wir haben gerade die Leibniz da. Die sind richtig cool.
Nur die echten mit 52 Zähnen [Bling].
Das wurde mit echten 52 Zähnen...
Übrigens, keine Produktplatzierung; haben wir uns selbst gekauft.
Dann nehmen wir hier gerade... Oha, die ist ja schon warm!
Wir haben hier eine Emaille-Schüssel. Sie ist induktionsgeeignet.
Jetzt machen wir als erstes die Kekse klein.
Ihr könnt es mit dem Messer machen oder ihr nehmt den
[Werbemusik] GEFU 2700 Speedwind pro. [Lacht]
Ich wollte es nur mal sagen.
Dann könnt ihr die Dinger auch ziehen.
Guck mal, sieht auch cool aus.
Vivi, nimm das mal kurz auf!
[Musik]
Jetzt können wir die ganzen Kekse da reinlegen. Zack, zack, zack!
Ich bin mal gespannt, was passiert.
[Musik]
Hat sogar perfekt gepasst – als ob alles abgemessen wäre.
Tut mir einen Gefallen: Macht es nicht zu fein,
weil es soll ja ein bisschen Crunchy Boden sein.
[Zerkleinerer]
Krass, gar keine Sauerei.
Ich kenne mich übrigens gut damit aus.
Das ist wie beim Rasenmäher: Zack!
[Zerkleinerer]
Oder wie bei einer Motorsäge.
Perfekt. Naja, ganz perfekt ist es noch nicht.
Ich glaube, das Ding wurde auch nicht entwickelt,
um Kekse kleinzumachen.
[Doing] Ich mache hier ab und zu mal einen Dirty Jamie Oliver Move
und mache alles mit den Händen – ich mag das viel mehr.
Jetzt haben wir hier schon die bereits vorgeheizte,
mir nicht gesagte Emaille-Schüssel. Jetzt nehmen wir die Butter.
Die Butter geben wir hier in die Emaille-Schüssel,
die ist schon vorgeheizt, und lassen sie einfach schmelzen.
Boah!
Bei niedriger Temperatur bitte.
Die Kekse geben wir auch gleich rein.
[Musik]
Dann einmal alles raus.
Wenn ihr nachher im Rezept... Es kommt darauf an, was ihr da reinmacht.
Es wurde für Oreo ausgerechnet und ich habe jetzt einfach
frei Schnauze die anderen Leibniz Kekse genommen.
Wenn ihr merkt, ihr braucht noch etwas mehr Butter
- man spricht im Schwäbischen von einem Muggeseggele -,
dann gebt ihr das einfach noch rein.
Aber ansonsten haltet ihr euch nach dem Rezept.
Alles schön schmelzen lassen.
Während sich die Butter mit diesem leckeren Koks...
[Polizeisirenen]
... Schokokeksteig verbindet, machen wir Folgendes;
auch ein ganz cooler Move von mir:
Ihr könnt z.B. das Pizzablech nehmen oder ihr nehmt
das Premium Backblech von der Sally – ist gar kein Thema.
Dann nehmt ihr die Dauerbackfolie, legt sie drauf
und stellt den Tortenring auf 24 cm ein.
Habt ihr das gesehen? Wahnsinn!
Jetzt stellt ihr es hier drauf.
Jetzt nehmt ihr den Keksteig, den ich mit dem Boden...
und einfach hier drauf.
So schnell geht das. Habt ihr das gesehen? Wahnsinn!
Jetzt verteilt ihr den Keksteig gleichmäßig.
Am Anfang habt ihr vielleicht ein bisschen Angst,
dass es zu wenig ist,
aber ihr müsst es wirklich ganz, ganz dünn machen,
dass es wirklich ein ganz, ganz dünner Keksteig,
also ein ganz dünner Boden ist.
So, perfekt!
Jetzt erhärtet die Butter.
Bevor das passiert, nehmen wir den Burger-Patty von Papa.
Das ist der Burger-Patty von Papa, aus Keramik von Gefu.
Damit forme ich richtig schön den Keksteig.
Da müsst ihr aber schnell sein.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr nicht so eine Burgerpresse habt,
dann nehmt irgendetwas mit einem flachen Boden, habt ihr 100%-ig.
Ein Glas, irgendetwas habt ihr daheim und könnt das dann flachdrücken.
Ganz cooles Tool eigentlich.
So, jetzt haben wir den Keksteig oder den Kuchenteig fertig.
Dann machen wir jetzt Folgendes:
Jetzt stellen wir es in den Kühlschrank, dass es schön abkühlen kann.
Während der Keksteig abkühlt, machen wir die Füllung oder den Teig
- wie ihr es nennen möchtet – für den Cheesecake.
Dazu brauchen wir 2 Schüsseln.
Dann fangen wir an,
und zwar kommen in die eine Schüssel die 400 g Sahne rein.
[Musik]
Das seid ihr von meiner Frau gewohnt; ich mache das auch.
Dann tun wir... Das macht meine Frau auch immer.
Sie hat immer so ein Ding. Nicht, dass es nachher heißt,
was ist das für ein Typ?
[Doing] Seine Frau arbeitet immer sauber und er nicht.
Bei den Handwerkern heißt es:
So wie dein Arbeitsplatz ist, so schafft man auch. Genau.
Das muss immer sauber sein. Ganz wichtig!
Dann nehmen wir die 4 TL San-apart.
Das ist ein Sahne- und Cremesteifmittel.
Also es gibt Sahnesteif. Das macht nur die Sahne steif.
Und dann gibt es aber San-apart. Das macht Sahne und Cremes steif.
Wollte ich nur mal sagen. So, 4 TL brauche ich.
[Musik]
Jetzt schlagen wir die Sahne mit diesem Gerät steif.
Erstmal checken, wie es funktioniert. Aha! Okay.
Ich fange langsam an.
[Musik]
Jetzt haben wir die Sahne fertig. Jetzt nehmen wir noch den Rest.
Jetzt verrühren wir den Quark, zack, den Frischkäse.
[Doing] Ich weiß nicht mehr, was Frischkäse und was Quark war,
aber es funktioniert. Dann nehmen wir noch den Puderzucker.
Vermischen, zack, auch noch mit rein.
Und restlichen San-apart – das sind jetzt nochmal 2 TL extra.
Das verrühren wir jetzt. Dann noch, klar, einen Schuss Vanilleextrakt.
[Musik]
So, jetzt verrühre ich es grob.
Jetzt einfach ein bisschen grob verrühren,
dass es eine homogene Masse wird.
Ihr braucht es gar nicht steif schlagen. Das war’s auch schon.
[Action-Musik]
[Jubel] Jetzt habt ihr Angst gekriegt! Habt ihr Angst gekriegt?
Das ist perfekt. Okay, ein bisschen Puderzucker ist rausgekommen.
Jetzt nehmen wir die Sahne und rühren sie unter;
unterheben sagt man dazu. Genau, unterheben.
Da nehme ich, ich glaube, einen anderen Kochlöffel.
Jetzt nehme ich die Sahne und hebe sie einfach unter.
[Musik]
Ihr seht – perfekt! Genau so muss sie sein.
So muss die Konsistenz sein.
Jetzt könnt ihr wirklich ein bisschen Freestyle machen.
Wenn ihr in eurem Süßigkeitenschrank noch Schokoflocken habt
oder von mir aus Kellog’s Smacks oder irgendetwas.
Das, worauf ihr gerade Lust habt.
Aber ich übertreibe es jetzt leider nicht.
Ich würde es gern übertreiben,
aber dann kriege ich Ärger von meiner Frau.
Also ich nehme jetzt den Keksteig, der abgekühlt ist
und fülle den Keksteig mit dieser Füllung. Genau, drüber, irgendwas
– ich kenne die Fachbegriffe nicht, aber ich mach’s jetzt.
Der Keksteig / Boden ist schon richtig hart geworden.
Ich fasse jetzt nicht rein, aber jetzt nehmen wir die Creme
und verteilen sie auf diesem Keksteig. Machen wir es so.
[Musik]
So, jetzt nehme ich die doppelt gewinkelte Palette.
Deswegen hat sie diesen Knick, diesen Winkel hier drin.
Ich verstreiche sie einfach schön glatt.
Das ist jetzt wie, wenn ich jetzt mauern würde.
[Musik]
Nachdem ich das gemacht habe, ist es jetzt ganz cool.
Wir können jetzt Folgendes machen: Ihr nehmt jetzt den Kuchen.
Ihr müsst ihn mindestens 3 Stunden abkühlen lassen.
Ihr könnt jetzt Folgendes machen:
Ihr könnt ihn ins Gefrierfach reinlegen,
wenn ihr Platz im Gefrierfach habt.
Dann reduziert sich natürlich die Zeit.
Oder ihr gebt ihn einfach für 3 Stunden in den Kühlschrank,
damit er richtig schön fest wird. Dann fangen wir mit dem an,
worauf ich richtig Lust darauf habe, und zwar auf das Garnieren.
Da habe ich nämlich ein paar coole Ideen,
auf die meine Frau jetzt vielleicht nicht gekommen wäre,
mache ich aber gleich.
Also, 3 Stunden Kühlzeit und dann sehen wir uns wieder.
[Musik und Uhr]
So, jetzt ist der Kuchen abgekühlt, 3 Stunden lang.
Es gehen auch 2 Stunden. Es kommt darauf an,
ob ihr ihn ins Gefrierfach oder in den Kühlschrank reinlegt.
Ich war jetzt im Garten
und habe noch ein bisschen was abgeschliffen und glasiert.
Die Zeit hat also gereicht.
Jetzt geht’s ums Garnieren und ums Dekorieren.
Da ist meine Frau natürlich ein absoluter Profi. Ich natürlich nicht!
Ich habe nicht dieses, wie soll ich sagen, dieses Feingefühl dafür.
Aber das soll ja ein richtig cooler
Leibniz Keks-and-Cream Kuchen werden.
Da habe ich mir überlegt, ich nehme noch die Minis dazu.
Eine richtig coole Geschichte. Die mag ich auch über alles.
Die sind echt cool. Und ich habe noch eine andere coole Idee gehabt:
Um ein kleines Muster hineinzukriegen, habe ich noch im Kühlschrank
[Modemgeräusche] Traubensirup gefunden.
Karamell wäre cooler gewesen, aber wir haben leider nichts da.
Deswegen nehme ich den, boah, den Traubensirup.
Diesen gebe ich jetzt hier hinein.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Jetzt mache ich einfach so ein rundes Muster.
Ich hoffe, ich kriege das jetzt hin und ich versaue es jetzt nicht.
Dann mache ich Kreisformen, wie so ein Hypnose-Ding.
Probiere ich jetzt mal.
[Musik]
Okay, hat jetzt nicht so funktioniert wie bei meiner Frau.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich hätte es vielleicht noch ein bisschen andicken sollen.
Keine Ahnung, wie sie das macht.
Jetzt versuche ich noch irgendwie die Torte zu retten.
Zu retten, ganz einfach: Ich nehme hier noch die Kekse.
Man ey, gerade, wo ich meine Frau brauche... [lacht]
So, jetzt nehme ich die Kekse und mache sie einfach rein.
Wie das vielleicht aussieht? Oh, sieht gar nicht schlecht aus.
[Musik]
Ich weiß ganz genau,
meine Frau würde es 100%-ig auf den Zentimeter ausmessen.
Das würde sie machen.
[Musik]
Jetzt mache ich es noch so herum.
Ich habe... Ich glaube, ich hätte... Aus mir wird kein Konditor.
Ich habe noch ein paar Kekse.
[Musik]
War nur ein halber. War abgebrochen, deswegen.
So, das sieht schon richtig gut aus.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine Idee.
Passt jetzt zwar nicht zu den Butterkeksen,
aber ich habe hier noch Toffifee. Genau, Toffifee ist wie Käse:
Wenn das Ding versaut ist,
einfach mit Käse überbacken oder einfach Toffifee draufgeben.
Ich hatte gestern noch mehr,
aber ich hatte gestern einen langen Netflix-Abend.
[Doing] Deswegen habe ich keine mehr.
Also mehr habe ich nicht mehr, aber die gebe ich auch noch darauf.
[Musik]
[Aufschrei] Du bist so blöd, Dennis. So blöd kann kein Mensch sein!
Komm her! Komm her!
[Dennis lacht]
Komm her!
DENNIS: Was machst du da?
MURAT: Ich backe gerade einen Kuchen.
DENNIS: Oh!
MURAT: Voll geil, gell?
DENNIS: Das sieht richtig gut aus.
MURAT: Cool, gell?
[Dennis lacht]
DENNIS: Du hast nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank. [Lacht]
Dann lässt man den einmal in der Küche allein und dann macht der sowas.
Ist das ein richtiges Rezept oder ist das nur jetzt...
MURAT: Ach was, das ist voll geil. Weißt du, was cool ist an dem Kuchen?
Ich bin mir ganz sicher...
DENNIS: Was ist das für ein Teig?
MURAT: Das ist ein Rührteig, [Doing] weil ich den gerührt habe.
DENNIS: Ich wusste nicht, dass du drehst.
Also, ich wollte eigentlich etwas mit dir bequatschen, aber...
MURAT: Das kannst du ruhig. Wir haben keine Geheimnisse. Sag ruhig!
DENNIS: Nein, ich wollte wegen Urlaub fragen.
MURAT: [Aufschrei] Nein! Nein! [Lacht]
Guck mal, das ist wie Kühe melken. Siehst du das? Zack!
DENNIS: Du könntest so ein Bauer sein. Weißt du? Der so melkt.
[Beide lachen]
Ich halte jetzt alles auf.
Ich komme später nochmal.
MURAT: Pass auf! Warte kurz, warte kurz! Du musst jetzt dabei sein.
Das ist jetzt voll das Ding. Jetzt pass auf.
Das ist ein Tortenringmesser.
DENNIS: Ist der Kuchen schon fertig? [Murat bejaht] Ach so.
MURAT: Und zwar nehme ich das Tortenringmesser
und löse es aus der Backform.
DENNIS: Das finde ich superpraktisch. Ich habe nämlich letztens gebacken.
Ich hatte das Ding nicht und der Kuchen ist zerbrochen.
[Musik]
BEIDE: Uii! Heeey!
DENNIS: Das sieht ja voll gut aus.
MURAT: Krass, oder? Warte kurz, warte kurz!
Ich muss noch ein paar Skills machen. Pass auf! Pass auf!
DENNIS: Jetzt drehst du aber durch. Ah, du willst jetzt...
MURAT: Nein, du musst jetzt schon...
DENNIS: Du könntest so ein... Iss es!
Mach noch einen Zensierbalken rein.
MURAT: Warte kurz!
DENNIS: Jo, jetzt übertreib nicht!
Du musst auch ein bisschen auf deine Figur achten.
MURAT: [Doing] Ich bin verheiratet. Boah, ist der Hammer, oder?
DENNIS: Sieht richtig schön aus. Was ist das unten für ein Boden?
MURAT: Ich weiß nicht, aber es schmeckt...
DENNIS: Hast du Resteverwertung gemacht?
MURAT: Nein, ich habe alles gemacht.
DENNIS: Pass mit deinem Dings auf!
MURAT: Guck mal, ich habe mit einer Torte alles gemacht.
Guck mal, siehst du das? Das nennt man Drip. Siehst du das?
Ich habe ein Drip Cake gemacht, ich hab ein Cheesecake gemacht.
Das sieht aus wie Stonehenge und in der Mitte habe ich... Baamm!
DENNIS: Nein, weißt du, was das ist? Wie heißt das? Domino!
Aber was ist das für ein Boden?
MURAT: Ach Gott, wenn ich dir das erzähle.
Und zwar ist das ein Leibniz Keks-and-Cream Boden.
DENNIS: [In amerikanischem Slang] Oh my God,
welcome to America’s Leibniz Cream-Boden.
MURAT: Genau deswegen habe ich es gemacht. Genau, genau, ja!
Das hat die NASA erfunden.
Die NASA hat damit normalerweise ihre Raumkapseln bezogen.
DENNIS: Ja, als Schutzschicht quasi.
MURAT: Genau, eine Schutzschicht. Dann habe ich das gemacht.
[Mit amerikanischem Akzent] Jetzt könnt ihr bestellen.
Geile Geschichte! Das sieht richtig cool aus, gell?
Da würde keiner darauf kommen,
dass ich eigentlich gar nichts draufhabe.
DENNIS: Kennst du das? Du bist Vater von 2 Kindern.
MURAT: Ja, ich kenne das.
DENNIS: Weißt du, dann kommt dein Kind zu dir und hat etwas gemalt.
Da sagst du ja auch, das hast du so schön gemalt.
Das kann ja noch nicht so gut malen. So sieht auch dein Kuchen aus.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: Jetzt pass auf!
DENNIS: Ich muss weiterarbeiten.
MURAT: Dennis, hau rein!
Auf jeden Fall sieht das Ding richtig geil aus, gell?
Ich bin sowas von überrascht, ehrlich, ich bin sowas von überrascht!
Hammer! Das ist wirklich alles: Drip, Käse... alles!
Jetzt müssen wir Folgendes machen:
Jetzt muss ich es irgendwie garnieren,
dass ich ein cooles Foto machen kann.
[Geräusche einer Grille]
Pass auf, dann hole ich mir so eine Tortendrehplatte
oder so eine Tortenplatte, okay?
Wartet kurz, ich bin gleich wieder da. Ich gehe kurz in den Südtrakt.
Da brauche ich vielleicht 1 Stunde, wenn ich die Bahn nicht verpasse.
Bin gleich wieder da!
JACQUES COUSTEAU: 3 Tage später...
Ich weiß, essen ist auch wichtig,
aber hier ist das Foto auch extrem wichtig,
weil das Ding sieht echt aus,
als hätte jemand richtig Ahnung gehabt von dem, was er macht.
Deswegen müssen wir gucken, welche Tortenplatte wir nehmen.
Und ich hole einen Tortenretter.
Jetzt wisst ihr, wozu man einen Tortenretter braucht,
und zwar muss man ihn von der Backfolie herunterholen
und auf eine schneidbare Unterlage legen.
Aha! So!
Ja, ich habe es gefunden!
Aha, Sarah! Komm jetzt!
[Jubel] Pass auf! Sieht voll krass aus, gell?
[Sarah lacht]
Du bist voll schockiert. Warte kurz!
Wie macht das die Sally? Die geht doch so drunter.
SARAH: Die macht das mit 2 Paletten.
[Modemgeräusche]
Hast du keine da?
MURAT: Warte kurz!
Mir ist gerade eingefallen, ich wohne gar nicht in dem Haus.
[Gelächter und Jubel]
Aber wir können das anders machen. Kennst du das?
In der Not frisst der Teufel Fliegen. [Sarah bejaht]
Pass auf, ich könnte ja auch das nehmen.
SARAH: Nein.
MURAT: Doch, komm! Das mache ich kurz.
Ich mache jetzt einen auf Wolverine.
SARAH: Ich kann’s nicht fotogra... Boah!
MURAT: Boah, okay!
SARAH: Ich kann’s nicht fotografieren, wenn es kaputt ist, gell!
MURAT: Sarah, das machen wir viel cooler.
Boah natürlich, die Torte ist doch hart. Pass auf!
SARAH: Ja, und dann kannst du sie...
MURAT: Warte!
SARAH: Ah, ah! Warte, warte! Du kannst so...
MURAT: Ja, ja! Ich mache das so. Aber sag mir nur, auf was?
Auf das weiße oder auf das weinrote?
SARAH: Ich finde, das beißt sich mit Weinrot. Ich würde weiß nehmen.
MURAT: Ja? Okay!
SARAH: Hast du gerade Toffifee in die Mitte gelegt?
MURAT: Ja, und zwar hier.
SARAH: Das machst du von hinten.
MURAT: Ah, oh Gott! [Sarah lacht]
Sarah, komm bitte. Guck, dass es nicht mehr kaputtgeht. Bitte!
SARAH: Warte, warte!
MURAT: Mach irgendetwas!
SARAH: Oh Gott!
Jetzt kannst du machen. Schieb es drunter!
MURAT: So, wie kriegen wir es jetzt wieder runter?
SARAH: Das schieben wir jetzt. Warte, mit dem, was du geholt hast.
MURAT: Ah, dass meine Hände nicht drankommen, gell?
SARAH: Aber mach es gerade drauf!
MURAT: Ich mache es doch.
SARAH: Gerade auf die Tortenplatte.
MURAT: Halt die Tortenplatte fest.
Das macht Sally immer allein? [Sarah bejaht]
Merkst du was? [Sarah bejaht]
SARAH: Tadaaa!
MURAT: Boah!
Wenn ihr euch manchmal fragt, wofür man dieses Gedöns immer gebraucht
- jetzt wisst ihr es! Wahnsinn, oder?
SARAH: Ja. Willst du sie noch kühlstellen?
MURAT: Nein, die ist schon kühl.
SARAH: Sicher? [Murat bejaht]
Ich habe es gerade gesehen, als du sie angehoben hast.
MURAT: Nein, die ist noch voll kühl. Glaub mir!
Mach jetzt die Fotos. Wäre richtig cool.
Aber mach diesmal schöne Bilder.
SARAH: Hast du schon wieder einen Toffifee im Mund? [Murat bejaht]
Wolltest du nicht auf Diät?
MURAT: Ja, bis vorhin.
Sarah, jetzt ohne Spaß. Mach echt coole Bilder, gell?
SARAH: Ich mache immer schöne Bilder! [Murat bejaht]
Immer da, wo du drauf bist.
MURAT: [Lacht] Ja genau!
So, Sarah macht jetzt richtig coole Bilder
und dann hole ich die Tortengöttin. Sie darf dann probieren.
Pass auf, lass das die Sally nicht sehen, okay?
SARAH: Sie läuft aber daran vorbei.
MURAT: Nein, bitte! Guck, dass sie es nicht sieht, okay?
Ich will sie einfach überraschen,
was für einen tollen Typen sie geheiratet hat.
Hammer, ehrlich! Wenn das Ding aussieht, wie es ist...
Äh, wenn es schmeckt, wie es aussieht, dann heiratet sie mich nochmal.
Dann mache ich den ganzen Laden hier selbst.
Dann heißt es in Zukunft: „Murats Welt“.
SARAH: Aber mach mir einen schönen Anschnitt danach, gell?
MURAT: Was ist das? Mit was?
SARAH: Fürs Foto, mit dem Messer, aber Tortenmesser!
Du hast schon wieder die Schublade...
MURAT: Ja, ich habe wieder...
Ich versuche immer die obere Schublade zu öffnen, aber das geht nicht,
weil die obere Schublade tot ist, weil da Steckdosen drin sind,
weil hier ein – tadaaa – Teppanyaki drin ist.
Und zwar ist Teppanyaki ein japanischer Grill.
Ich bin zwar Türke, aber was soll’s.
Perfekt! Gleich geht’s weiter.
[Musik]
Sarah hat die Fotos gemacht. Die Fotos sehen übrigens gerade so aus.
Könnt ihr mal sehen, hat sie richtig cool gemacht.
Sarah macht das wahnsinnig gut!
Jetzt hole ich the one and only Torten-Queen, Kuchenbackkönigin
– Sally!
Schatz, kommst du bitte rein?
SALLY: Kann ich bitte mit so einem Applaus aus dieser Tür raus?
MURAT: Ja, ganz, ganz toll! Jawoll! Yeah!
SALLY: Könnt ihr die Tür zeigen?
MURAT: Warte kurz, ich mache sie auf.
[Jubel]
Sei ehrlich, sowas hast du noch nicht gesehen, gell?
SALLY: Oh!
MURAT: Schön, gell? [Sally stimmt zu]
Sagst du das jetzt nur, weil ich ein kleines Kind bin
oder sagst du das, weil du das echt toll findest?
SALLY: Ehm, wo sind die Oreo Kekse?
MURAT: Die Oreo Kekse habe ich aus Versehen gegessen.
SALLY: [Schockiert] 200 g?!
MURAT: Ja, 220 g waren es ganz genau. 20 Kekse sind 220 g.
Auf jeden Fall fand ich die Leibniz einfach cooler.
Ich wollte einfach ein Keks-and-Cream Cake machen,
weil Oreo macht jeder und ich bin ja anders.
SALLY: Hast du da Schwarztee darüber gekippt? [Lacht]
MURAT: Nein, ich habe Traubensirup darüber gemacht.
SALLY: Ach so.
MURAT: Pass auf, jetzt probiere es einfach mal, okay?
SALLY: Schneidest du gerade mit dem Hackfleischmesser die Torte?
MURAT: Ja. Du musst jetzt einfach mal probieren, okay?
Aber du kannst echt ehrlich sein, weißt du.
SALLY: Sarah hat sich beschwert.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hatte nur 1 Toffifee für die Dekoration.
MURAT: Ja. Jetzt pass auf, du probierst jetzt einfach mal aus,
aber du kannst... Ich glaube, die Zuschauer sind nicht sauer,
wenn dieses Rezept nicht funktioniert hat. Aber...
SALLY: Ja, aber was ist mit der Oreo Torte, die ich dir geschrieben habe?
MURAT: Ich wollte einfach etwas Anderes machen.
Ich wollte nicht einfach das machen, was du mir immer sagst,
sondern ich wollte mal mein eigenes Ding machen.
SALLY: Ist ja auch okay. Also ich finde...
Also ich will deine Torte nicht haten. Ich finde, sie ist kreativ.
Sieht aus wie beim Domino Day.
Aber du hättest sie andersherum stellen können.
Dann hätte man sie so „Zack!“ und dann so „Zschuuu!“.
MURAT: Ey, cool!
SALLY: Oder? [Murat stimmt zu]
Kennst du Domino Day noch?
MURAT: Nein. Ich hatte keine Kindheit. Ich war arbeiten.
SALLY: Wir haben es jedes Jahr mit meinen Eltern geguckt – Domino Day.
MURAT: Also das ist ein richtiger... Guck mal, das da habe ich genommen.
SALLY: Das ist jetzt aber kein Aprilscherz?
MURAT: Nein, ist kein Aprilscherz. Außerdem haben wir Mai.
Nein, wir haben April.
[Bedrohliche Musik]
Und, wie ist es?
SALLY: Hmm!
MURAT: Gut, gell?
SALLY: Ja. Mit dem Messer in deiner Hand kann ich ja nur gut sagen.
Doch, schmeckt lecker.
MURAT: Ehrlich? Komm, sei ehrlich jetzt! Lass mich auch mal probieren.
SALLY: Wir sind Mann und Frau.
MURAT: Mmh! Mmh!
SALLY: Ich finde sie echt gut. Und du hast echt so Traubensirup darüber?
Traubenmelasse? [Murat bejaht]
Tahin Pekmez.
MURAT: Weil ich noch ein bisschen etwas Anderes darauf haben wollte.
Was auch cool gewesen wäre: Karamell.
Wäre auch cool gewesen.
SALLY: Aber wäre vielleicht zu süß.
MURAT: Hatten wir noch Karamell irgendwo da?
SALLY: Drüben.
MURAT: Echt? Ja, okay. Ich glaube, dann wäre es zu süß gewesen.
SALLY: Ich habe ja selbstgemachten Karamell.
MURAT: Also ihr braucht jetzt nicht denken,
dass der Kuchen jetzt extrem pappsüß ist. Ist er wirklich nicht.
Durch diese Traubenmelasse ist er wirklich nicht pappsüß.
SALLY: Ja, ich finde es gut.
MURAT: Die Idee mit dem Ding war auch cool
und das Toffifee in der Mitte war einfach ein Alibi.
SALLY: Jetzt weiß ich, woran mich das erinnert.
MURAT: Woran?
SALLY: An unsere Türkeireise, an die Ruinen dort. Da waren doch auch so...
MURAT: Aha, und das sieht aus wie eine Ruine, oder was?
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Wie diese Wände, die so einzeln stehen...
MURAT: Sei ruhig, bevor du dich in irgendwelche Sachen reinmanövrierst.
SALLY: Nein, nicht aus der römischen Zeit. Was war es?
Im Ephesos. [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Guck mal, ich finde es auch cool,
wenn du Torten in die Hand nehmen kannst.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Hauptsache, er isst so eine Sahnetorte aus der Hand. [Lacht]
MURAT: Voll cool. Guck mal, hörst du das? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Und wer kriegt dieses eine Stück Toffifee in der Mitte?
MURAT: Das ist der Geck bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Das kriegt der... wo das letzte Stück ist, kriegt noch das Ding.
SALLY: Weißt du, was ich kenne? Du nimmst so einen runden Ausstecher
und stichst das Tortenstück in der Mitte rund aus
und die drumherum dann so...
MURAT: Hey, wäre auch eine coole Idee gewesen, aber ich bin schon froh,
dass ich die Dinger habe gerade hinstellen können.
SALLY: Okay. Die Bilder werden bestimmt schön. [Murat stimmt zu]
Ich bin sehr stolz auf dich. Mach weiter so!
MURAT: Ihr könnt das daheim ganz einfach nachmachen. Haut einfach drauf,
was ihr möchtet. Außer Gemüse ist alles in Ordnung.
SALLY: Backst du mir dieses Jahr eine Geburtstagstorte?
MURAT: Mach ich.
SALLY: Und eine Hochzeitstorte?
MURAT: Nein, doch! Mach ich.
SALLY: Und eine Jahrestorte?
MURAT: Ja, mein Gott! Ich backe nur noch. Ich bin hier ein Bäcker.
Mein Name ist Boris Becker.
SALLY: Wann haben wir unseren Jahrestag?
MURAT: Am 21. Juni.
SALLY: Nein, das ist Hochzeitstag.
Oh mein Gott! Er hat’s drauf!
MURAT: 10. Oktober.
SALLY: 19. Oktober.
Hey, was ist mit dir los?
MURAT: 10. oder 19. Oktober?
SALLY: 19. Aber dass es Oktober war, wusstest du. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Langsam geht’s.
SALLY: Wie heißen unsere Kinder?
MURAT: Samira und Ela.
SALLY: Sehr gut. [Beide lachen]
MURAT: Also, wie gesagt, macht das nach. Hat echt Spaß gemacht.
Ist auch wirklich voll easy. Kann wirklich jeder nachmachen, auch ich.
SALLY: Komm, back gleich noch etwas, okay?
MURAT: Und tut mir einen Gefallen: Kommentiert einfach,
lasst einen Daumen da, macht ein Abo, irgendwie sowas. Heißt das so?
SALLY: Lasst einen Daumen da...
MURAT: Ach so, ja. Macht einen Daumen hoch und dann abonnieren.
Dann verpasst ihr nicht mehr ein Video mit mir zusammen.
SALLY: Wäre jammerschade.
MURAT: Ja. Macht’s gut! Tschüss!
SALLY: War echt gut.
MURAT: Ja, sage ich doch. Kannst du die anderen auch probieren lassen?
SALLY: Ja. Aber es sitzt nur noch der Veganer oben.
MURAT: Ja, egal.
SALLY: Zwei. [Lacht]
MURAT: So, und ich räume auf.
SALLY: Okay, ich gehe dann mal.
¡Adiós!
MURAT: Da ist sie doch einfach im Schrank verschwunden. Der Wahnsinn!
Hammer ey! Schmeckt echt super! Ohne Witz! Ganz ehrlich.
Hätte ich niemals gedacht. Der ist nicht süß. Der ist super.
[Musik]